hey what is up guys I'm cabby HD here we
all know plenty of smartphones come out
every year
clearly 2015 was no exception to that
rule so this video is your one-stop shop
for picking one this video will
hopefully give you all the information
you need to be able to confidently sign
that contract with a great choice in a
smart phone so if all the smart phones
released during 2015 these are going to
be the best in each category and as I do
for the smartphone Awards I'm going to
give you guys a first-place Best Overall
option but also a second-place also
still pretty good the runner-up and then
an honorable mention or two to round it
out so this is the smartphone Awards
2015 so first up we got the top big
phones of the year now smart phones get
seems bigger and bigger every single
year and often the top of the line
option is huge but only some of them
really take advantage of their size so
these are the best big smart phone
options right now number one is the
Samsung Galaxy Note 5 it definitely
qualifies as a big phone with a 5.7 inch
quad HD Super AMOLED display and it
really takes advantage of all that real
estate packing a big battery big specs
and a bunch of software features that
really take advantage of that awesome
screen so love it or hate it this is one
big advantage of a software skin on a
phone like this it's adding a bunch of
productivity and fun features that stock
Android just doesn't have so my second
place option for best big phone of the
year is going to go to LG's v10 it
showed up closer to the end of the year
but it really showed up LG's own g4 as
one of the best phones they've ever made
the v10 is rocking a 5.7 inch IPS
display and it's definitely a big phone
with big specs and again a lot of the
features are those similar to Samsung's
short of that stylus to best take
advantage of the extra real estate and
you can see that in reviews I'll have
all the reviews of all the phones I
talked about in this video in the links
right below that like button and I have
honorable mentions in the big phones
category - the Nexus 6p and the samsung
galaxy s6 edge+ both over 5.5 inch
displays and both really premium now on
the opposite end of the spectrum we have
the best compact smartphones of the year
and it seems like a true high-end but
also really compact smartphone is
becoming a bit of a rare breed since all
these high-end smartphones are getting
so big the more compact counterparts are
more low-end but not so with these
best choices so my number one pick for
best compact smartphone of the Year by
these criteria is the iPhone 6s and it
wins this award because it is still a
true full no compromises flagship this
is everything that Apple has to offer
all their latest innovations and all
their highest end specs so really even
if Apple does make some sacrifices to
get their phone this thin there's one
thing you can't deny and that's the
ridiculously fast performance of the new
a9 chip so if speed is your thing if you
want a really fast and relatively
compact phone at 4.7 inches then iPhone
6s is a great bet my very close second
place for best compact smartphone is
going to go to the Sony Xperia z5
compact because Sony's doing a lot of
the same stuff they're bringing in the
high-end features from the Xperia z5 an
z5 premium into a much smaller package
alright the next category for the
smartphone awards is the best camera in
a smartphone this year and this is a
category that heated up a lot we got a
lot of really good smartphone cameras
this year so the margin between first
place and second place and third place
even fourth fifth and sixth is razor
thin so you're probably going to get a
good option no matter which one and easy
pick but my number one pick for best
camera in a smartphone is again going to
go to the samsung galaxy note 5 note 5
has the best point-and-shoot camera on a
smartphone right now by a hair it's
really that fast customisable camera app
combined with the razor-sharp 16
megapixel photos with that punchy color
and salih dynamic range that makes the
quality hard to deny it's also a great
4k video shooter and you'll find the
same optics also in galaxy s6 s6 edge
and s6 edge+ so I guess sort of lump
those all into this number one placement
I don't know Samsung over the past
couple years has been getting really
good at smartphone cameras now my number
two pick and again this is a very close
number two is going to go to the LG v10
the image quality out of the v10 s
camera is right up on par with the note
5 and if you're experienced you can go
right ahead and basically match it with
some cases in manual mode but the v10
camera really shines with its software
which also includes a manual video mode
making this by far and away the best
choice for someone looking to shoot a
lot of smartphone video but it doesn't
hurt that the auto mode is pretty great
too and I got to give honourable
mentions to these phones I've taken a
lot of pictures with my iPhone 6s plus
and my Nexus 6p which have some of the
best and quickest camera apps in any
smartphone and both take very reliable
quality photos and again the margin of
difference between the first and fifth
best smartphone cameras is not that big
so you get a good choice either way
alright next category best budget
smartphone of 2015 and this is a
category that again heated up a lot
good phones got really cheap cheap
phones got really good we saw a lot of
quality stuff in the budget department
this year to the point where it's
actually kind of hard to define what
exactly is budget is it sub $400 or is
it sub $300 only either way there's no
doubt about it in my mind the number one
pick for best budget smartphone came
over here it's the oneplus X whatever
debate there may be about the amount of
a budget smartphone this one definitely
qualifies it's just 250 bucks off
contract no invite very inexpensive for
the material choices the build quality
and overall experience this phone
manages to deliver the display is
definitely one of its best features it's
the 5-inch 1080p AMOLED display with
those deep blacks and vivid colors but
there's a whole lot more to it as well
with metal rails expandable storage and
the custom OS definitely worth checking
out that full review now right after
that I have a phone I came in just shy
of $400 off contract which in my book is
still budget considering a 6 7 and $800
phones we have on this table so I'm
going to give that second place to the
new Moto X Pierre this is one of the
more important phones of the year
because of the precedent is set for
flagship phones not having to be super
expensive when it came out it was the
highest end phone Motorola made a legit
flagship high-end specs 21 megapixel
camera and near stock Android with a few
moto extras but yet it sits on the shelf
at a super competitive price and I think
that played a big part as a spark plug
for a lot of the budget focus phones we
saw come after it now running out the
best budget stuff of the year I got two
more you could consider sort of pseudo
budget depending on the way you look at
it but I got to hand it to the oneplus 2
and the Nexus 5x 1 + 2 was daily driver
quality for me for a while with a lot of
those custom software features I loved
and a solid build again at 389 bucks and
the Nexus 5x is your pure stock Android
phone even taking the same camera optics
from the higher-end Nexus 6p and putting
them all in a lightweight $329 package
alright so the next category in
smartphone awards is a new one for this
year in 2015 and it's battery life best
battery life in a smart phone and I'm
adding this specifically because I'm
neglected in the highest-end flagships
in favor of stuff like thinness and
other features we may or may not like or
need so I'm rewarding the ones that
don't do that and my number one pick is
got to go to the Motorola Droid Maxx
battery life was the main focus on the
Droid Maxx - moto boasts two days of
battery and while I can't exactly vouch
for all that it is rocking a 3630
million power cells so huge on paper and
a legit all-day smartphone with that
1080p display and an ear stock Android
experience if you're one of those people
who demands five-and-a-half hours of
screen on time or is constantly using
your phone for heavy stuff like
navigation or periscope or anything that
kills your battery max - now I have a
second place in the battery life
Department that's because after recent
Android M updates Nexus 6p is getting me
some of the best battery life I've ever
had on a high-end smartphone I'm getting
like near five hours of screen on time
now so that's awesome to see and I also
got to give a shout-out to LG for not
coming out with just one but two
high-end smartphones with removable
batteries the LG v10 and the LG g4 both
have big removable batteries and that's
pretty much the fastest form of quick
charge you can have now the next
category is a little favorite of mine
it's the most improved award for company
that improved the most this year and
there's a couple guys I could give this
to but right now the number one most
improved I think by far in my opinion is
blackberry again with the BlackBerry
Prive my full review of this one says it
all but it's again by far the best
BlackBerry ever and the most competitive
one in a long time it's unfortunately
still really expensive and still
definitely not for everyone with the
version of Android it's running with a
whole bunch of its customizations and
the slider keyboard that form factor but
it's I guess refreshing in a weirdly
throwback way to see blackberry
continuing to get better so now I have a
category called the design award and
last year I called it like the craziest
design this year I just want to reward
the best design in my opinion and
there's a bunch of smart phones on this
table you may or may not be able to
identify most of them by the way they
look on the back but some of them are
more striking than others and some of
them are more industrial than others and
I got reward that so my favorite right
now of this year is a samsung galaxy s6
edge+ in a sea of black slab phone's not
gonna lie it would be pretty easy for
almost any slightly unusual one to stick
out but this one is just pretty even if
it's not gold the slow
helping edges and the display melting
over right before the metal rails is
dope I hope we see another edge phone
from Samsung next year I runner-ups in
this design category two phones that had
particularly awesome displays this year
on the front of them first of all being
the Motorola Droid turbo 2 this guy has
a shatterproof display legit and yes I
can vouch that it survives real drops
and the other one is the Sony Xperia z5
premium rocking a full freaking 4k
display it's super early for these but
when it kicks in to full 4k it looks
dope I made a video all about that
screen next up is an award I hate to
have to give but I always will it's the
bust of the year for 2015 the one I
guess the biggest letdown in a
smartphone world and there's a couple
again that I could possibly give this to
but the one that stands out is the HTC
One a9 even if we ignore the striking
resemblance to a certain Apple flagship
the a9 as a replacement to the HTC One
m9 to me is disappointing because it
makes it a flagship with a lot of
sacrifices it sacrificed being able to
shoot 4k video for a certain chip it
sacrifice the legendary boom sound
speakers for a home button I mean I hate
to talk about for more than I have to
but this was easily the biggest letdown
of the year for me and I'll have my eye
on HTC that much more to see next year's
phone so that leaves us with the final
category which is your MVP the best
smartphone of the year in my opinion and
again these are very subjective and I'll
have all the reviews to as many of the
phones that I'm talking about today as
possible in the description right below
that like button but the best phone of
the year is the best overall contender
and it's often one that I use for the
longest period of time during the year
for that exact reason and my number one
choice is the Nexus 6p I would say my
heavy use of this guy hints at my
preference for a cleaner build of
Android and this is as clean as it gets
awesome display awesome battery life
awesome camera great performance great
build quality I mean this is a complete
package from top to bottom it competes
in every category and it's not even the
most expensive one on this list so it's
kind of hard to argue with Nexus 6p my
number-two in the MVP race is the Galaxy
Note 5 I could have easily given it to
the samsung galaxy s6 edge+
what a name but I actually just felt
that the feel in the hand of the note 5
won me over a little bit but I use this
phone for a while this year as well
note 5 is also stacked I give it best
display on any smartphone best camera on
any smartphone and some of the best
specs available I'm less of a fan of the
software it's not for everyone like I
said and this also happens to be a super
fingerprint magnet and one of the
slippery phones of all time but you know
skin will clean that right up and I use
this phone for a while to sear as well I
got a couple honorable mentions in the
MVP race this year just for a couple of
different reasons first is the Moto X
2015 like I said earlier this guy set a
precedence for what you can do on a
budget and I feel like during the year
after this came out we actually saw more
quality budget smartphones start to
appear and competitive pricing for
flagships overall now is even more of a
big deal my second honorable mention is
the iPhone 6s and 6s plus and that's
simply because they're the fastest
phones I've used this year Apple I don't
know what exactly you did with that a 9
ship but iOS just flies I love it and I
can't forget to shout out Microsoft's
950 XL which was by far and away the
best Windows Phone choice of this year
let me know if you guys want to see a
full review of that but I think that's
the pretty easy choice so there you have
it guys there's clearly a lot of great
smartphones released in 2015 and the
choice is there for almost everyone so
whether you need something with
particularly great camera for photos and
videos or you need a really long battery
life if you travel a lot or you need a
particularly compact or a large phone
depending on your taste the choice is
there you'd be kind of hard-pressed to
go wrong with one of the ones we talked
about in this video so there you have it
and if you know someone who might be in
the market for buying a smartphone you
probably want to share this video with
them to save you a lot of time and
explaining thanks for watching this one
now talk to you guys in the next one
peace
you